A scanning machine is a virtual or physical machine that runs scans.
You can run scans on the same machine as the web server and enterprise server to begin with.
When you follow the installation wizard, this is a default option that is selected.
Alternatively, you can set up as many external machines as you want and use them as dedicated scanning machines.
In this way, you can spread your scans across multiple scanning machines to avoid overloading a single machine.
You can assign a maximum number of current requests that can be run on each machine.
Please refer to the system requirements section for more information about how many machines you might need to deploy.
Note that if you decide to use external scanning machines, you need to authorize them in BurpSuite Enterprise Edition before you can use them to run scans.
On standard deployments, as opposed to Kubernetes deployments, scanning machines exist in one of several scanning pools.
These pools are used to manage the resources for different kinds of scans or for scanning different sorts of sites.
To assign the machine to a different pool, see Managing Scanning Pools.
The machine to a different pool is used to manage the machine.
!